remembering a young life lost too soon
sunday august 29 marking one year since
leslie palacio's death the man accused
of killing her eric rangala barra still
on the run tonight sally jeremiah spoke
to the family of the 22 year old who say
there isn't a day that goes by that they
don't think about her
i feel like every anniversary that comes
up i feel like i'm
really those moments again and it's just
horrible being here with the house quiet
it makes me feel so empty inside kaylee
palacio one of leslie's younger sisters
says despite a year going by it feels
just like yesterday when her family got
the news and her world turned upside
down it went by
super fast
and you know like everyone
is out here you know
with their siblings and
having a fun time when i'm over here you
know grieving and the grief unbearable
at times i miss her very much the family
describes leslie as independent
hard-working and always positive she's a
great person
and that she taught me some so much
stuff and a role model to kaylee i'm not
going to stop helping people because i'm
doing it for her i'm doing in her memory
i want people to remember her in a
positive way by caring for one another
most importantly i don't want her name
to be forgotten kaylie along with her
family attorney ophelia marcarion have a
message for the community keep following
the case to keep leslie's spirit alive
to know that we're not going to stop
it's been really really hard knowing
that it's been a year
and eric rangel is still out on the
streets i'm just not done
i don't know over here with me anymore
may she rest in peace sally caramillo 8
news now
while eric rangelabara has yet to be
captured his dad jose rangel was
recently sentenced to two years behind
bars for being an accessory to murder
for destroying evidence in that case